do you have a sneaking suspicion that  there is someone watching you every  click you might have a rat remote access  Trojan a rat or a key logger is a  program which allows hackers to read  which Keys you clicked and in which  sequence even an employer can place a  key Locker on your computer if your  browser suddenly starts to slow down and  your cursor begins to lag or even  disappears altogether well it seems your  secret chat with your co-workers is no  longer a secret how can you restore your  privacy the first thing to do is to  check your activity monitor or task  manager if you use Windows Google any  suspicious titles or applications  otherwise you might accidentally delete  something important then you need to  clear the folder containing temporary  files keyloggers can sometimes hide in  there what happens on your keyboard  should stay on your keyboard it's  definitely worth investing in a good  antivirus software before taking a  stroll through the online jungle